i've got to get to the juicy smolette
trial i've got to get to it it's much
more important than the elaine maxwell
trial if you ask me because we actually
are learning new things so jesse
smallett now he's changing his story a
million times and he apparently had a
little bit of a weird relationship with
those dudes that he set up to go pretend
to rob him and say it's maggot country
even though they were giant you know
they pretended to be white supremacists
but they were giant nigerian dudes
so
now what what smollett is trying to do
to get off
on this trial is he's just trying to
pester the prosecutor and play the race
card and play the victim
so the prosecutor here was reading text
messages from jessie smallette right
these are messages to and from jesse
smellette and in it jesse smellet uses
the n-word you know the n-word the
n-word it's the only word that we're not
allowed to say it has the sacred
significance of the name of god for the
ancient israelites we're not allowed to
ever say the n-word but jesse smallett
said the n-word and so the prosecutor
reading the texts says the n-word
and then jesse smallett says hey you
can't use that word don't stop using
that word stop using the word that i
used and the prosecutor said well i'm
not good what do you want me i'm reading
your texts dude
no say a different word call it the n
word don't say the n word you have to
call it the n word you know the e n word
and the prosecutor says no i think i'm
just going to read the text i'm not
going to edit your language
silver and gold silver and gold everyone
wishes for silver and are you like yukon
cornelius do you wish
for gold specifically
well acre will let you get your hands on
some gold now you might say michael i
don't have a whole lot of money what if
i told you you could start investing in
physical gold for as little as thirty
dollars a month
you can i know you'll probably call me a
liar but it's true you can acre has this
ingenious way to invest where when your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars monthly monthly you subscribe
to the gold 30 bucks a month then once
it reaches that threshold they'll
discreetly ship acre gold to your house
acre has introduced a new 100 a month
subscription to a 5 gram gold bar if you
want to up the ante great way to start
getting invested in physical precious
metals i have enjoyed investing in
physical precious metals and
specifically
in acre gold go to getacregold.com right
now
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url is acres
giving away a gold bar to qualify for
the giveaway tweet or post why you
should be the recipient and mention at
get underscore acre that is get acre
gold dot com slash
knowles this is
a perfect example of
the logic that animates modern
liberalism and leftism
don't do what i did hey you can't do
what i did kind of ties in with the
freedom caucus stuff because the freedom
caucus tends to take the political fight
to the left and then
people who are a little bit more
moderate or a little more genteel they
say well we can't do that that's wrong
that's we can't we can't engage in some
of the tactics that the left engages and
that would then would be just like them
and
basically they're saying we need to
indulge in this kind of no don't don't
do what i did but it's not going to work
we should never do things that are
immoral or unjust but as a tactical
matter we can't just let the libs get
away with everything we can't let them
get away with having their own
completely different set of standards
than the ones they hold us by whether
that is in the courts whether that is in
prisons whether that is in the media
whether that is in politics generally
can not
do it got to take the fight to the lives
[Music]
[Music]
you